hey 42 here one in four people have a
hole in their heart welcome to RIF 59 of
the 60 oldest living people are women
a newborn blue whale puts on 14 stone
every day to sleep for one night in
every bed in Las Vegas would take 288
years a common form of public apology in
Japan is shaving one's head full fat or
whole milk only contains 3.5 percent fat
the critically endangered Kakaako bird
has a strong pleasant musky odor which
allows predators to easily locate it
hence it is critically endangered two
teaspoonfuls of Botox are enough to kill
everyone in Britain the hole in the
ozone layer over Antarctica is twice the
size of Europe Arnold Schwarzenegger
earned more than 20,000 pound per word
for his role in Terminator 2
in spite of women and children first men
are twice as likely as women to survive
shipwrecks during 19th century
construction of Paris's underground
sewers workers found lost medieval
dungeons jewels and the skeleton of an
orangutan that had previously escaped
from the zoo the richest 85 people in
the world have as much money as the
poorest 3.5 billion the Dutch crown
jewels are made of fake pearls fish
scales and colored foil 80% of Italians
under 30 years old live with their
parents in 2013 a PayPal computer error
briefly made a man in Pennsylvania the
richest person in the world thanks for
the view subscribe for more thoughty2
you